what's the difference between in-person
and online play Given that context yeah
well online poker and live poker it's
the same game right same it's poker but
it's different in so many levels right
um I think playing online you have to
focus far more on fundamentals you know
on Game Theory you don't have the added
bonus of looking across the table and
getting any sense of whether your
opponent is strong or weak they're
bluffing whatever you know and and also
because online poker those that play it
you play far more hands like some of
these guys are playing 10 20 tables at
the same time yeah right so you're just
you're hitting the long run really
quickly and you're creating a database
on your opponents right so let's have
you know online I can see your data I'm
like well this guy he's playing 40 of
hands he's betting the river 80 of the
time so now I can use that data and you
know explain you that way when you play
Live you don't have that
do you enjoy playing online I enjoy so
with online poker I enjoy the
convenience of it because you know you
can be on your couch in your underwear
not leave your house do also play
multiple games at the same time you do
try to play one game I typically like to
play one or two but I can play up to
four I find that past four uh it's hard
for me to keep up and keep track of
what's actually happening you know it's
a different mindset required like a lot
of these young guys they're accustomed
to 20 tables at a time
it feels like the purity of the game is
gone it's much more robotic right so if
you're playing 20 tables you're just
making decisions based on like what you
you know you're not thinking about the
the depth of the situation and what just
happened 15 minutes ago you don't even
know what happened because you can't pay
attention to all that at once